all right
next one
t.i was at a comedy show where i guess
he was going to perform and the host had
made a joke about the sexual assault
allegations with t.i and his wife there
is video of ti going off on the host let
me see it yeah
this winter yeah
you coming with that turtleneck
[ __ ] evidence because there was no
[ __ ] crap
you took the mic from here
[Music]
and if you keep on playing with me [ __ ]
i'm gonna [ __ ] continue to confront
you publicly verbally
i'm not playing with you
he's cool
now she's mad
they start playing one of his hits he
starts they cut his mic off
did you see uh he ran the light 20
minutes at the store [ __ ] and i just
keep putting them up yeah the guy
someone came and tapped him like hey
you're gonna get it yeah you gotta get
off this ain't going well yeah because
because they i guess they were lighting
them a lot
and uh he i don't i just think he didn't
no i think who knows you think you know
100
it was in the belly room and he had to
go behind like basically the black
curtain yeah to like because he didn't
want to like go up on stage and tap him
so he tried to do it kindly you see he's
just like yeah his hand touches him he
goes and he goes did you
you ran like like 20 minutes that's
insane yeah yeah that's not the best way
to get into stand up yeah but just
pissing off all the comics running the
light is his music thing he's not doing
as much of it anymore
i don't know if he's dropped anything
but i mean
and
and within recent i'm not i'm not too
sure i listen to a lot of his older
stuff i don't know
if he's dropped anything as far as
recent i don't think so